speaking of jacqueline breyer we just
spoke to him yeah and
he's a bit of a record keeper he oh my
god sent us a document of every
appearance oh my god wow
i believe that
yeah and
he was on 78 times oh my god they're all
here and then at the end he made a list
and we're probably gonna post this with
the episode ways that i've died slash
been abused
all the different ways he was killed or
named on in sketches on the show in
sketches not in real life like yeah yeah
yeah there might have been some
carryovers
jack was always money in the bank and
this is before
before 30 rock yeah we used him and so
no
no one knew who he was but he was just
this hilarious and is a hilarious
performer and we would um
you know use him in all these different
ways and
i always would do this improv where
whenever jack was around i'd be the kind
of cruel callous city slicker right who
was like
where where
jack mcbrear i knew i smelled you know
horse manure you know did you muck out
the barn and he no i did not serve yes
and he is so
jack is so good at going with it he'd be
like sir that is wrong i am not you know
sir that is and he would and he would
really commit to it
so i would commit to my guy right and he
would commit to his guy and what i
didn't know is that the crew was
watching all this
and they thought it was real yeah so you
know i mean i love jack but literally
jack would be at the double doors
waiting to rehearse and i would see him
out of the corner of my head and start
sniffing the air gun
[Music]
sounds to me like somebody just came
fresh
from the you know the hog farm and he'd
be like sir i most certainly did not and
what if i do i came for yeah i came from
my condominium in midtown i'd be like oh
you kind of did you get scared about the
elevator
that moving box i did not serve i know
perfectly well what an elevator is and
we would do this so at one point we
would just do this
and we would really commit to it and
neither one of us would break
and i remember uh one time i'm walking
out and there's a couple of members of
the crew
and a cameraman they're standing around
and a sound guy and they're like can we
talk to you for a second and i said yeah
and they went
you know jack's a really good guy and
you're pretty rough on him wow and i
said guys i love jack and they're like
well if you love jack maybe
you really i was like are you no no no
jack jack come here yeah like tell them
and um his deadpan is just too good his
deadpan was so so good and it would be
great if he was like
thanks guys
i've been waiting for someone to
intervene yeah
so so he
what happened was
and this is something like you guys i
think can it can attest to which is that
i don't
have to me yeah
i don't have i don't have boundaries but
i also don't segment things meaning
comedy's not something that i do when
people are around right and it's time to
do professional combination my thing
whatever you want to call it good or bad
is happening all the time right yes so
um and i just did because we had to wait
to even just do this podcast
and i had no i just have socks on here
at the airwolf studios and there's a
smooth cement floor and i'm dancing
around
and doing different characters and
charging all of us like a bulb charging
all of you like a bowl and acting like a
total ass
not acting my age or anyone's age at all
i mean a four-year-old would be
disgusted
but
i this is what i do all the time so i
have
um i will
jack will text me something
and i'll text back like just as it's
jack prayer and we're friends and he'll
text me something like um you know um
hey you plan to have your christmas
party this year and i'll go
where where where you know i'll be
texting him back and saying things like
you know um you know the problem is if
you bring the mule
you know everybody's gonna want to bring
a mule and we can't have a christmas
party and he'll text back and say it'd
just be one thing
no and i'll be like come on jack and
he'll type back like this is wrong this
is wrong what you're doing and he'll
commit to his thing and it'll be
sometimes it's one o'clock in the
morning and i'm
chuckling and doing this
city slicker guy from like 1911 and he's
doing his thing and it's for nobody
it's for nobody it's madness